you wrote something
in may 14 2020 about the covet 19 and
you just talked about it here right now
saying
every sunday we get together with the
family in pittsburgh we're right next to
each other we have dinner etc etc even
during covid
so that means you have more than 10
people in the house if you're doing that
here's 21 people in violation of the
governor's order that's right so i'm
going to read this i'm going to read
this and i'm going to turn it over to
you where you can share your thoughts on
this
as a physician specializing in forensic
pathology i'm only going to read two
paragraphs not the whole thing
i am well aware the importance of
preventative health care measures and
the tragedy of death and every one of
the 21 000 autopsies that have performed
in the last
63 years i've always thought about the
descendant's life and what the
significance of that death is likely to
have been to the family
friends and society however at the same
time as a sensitive and caring human
being husband father and
grandparent i'm also very much aware of
what it means to be alive enjoying
appreciating being with the family and
friends accordingly i am rather
puzzled by the limited amount of
coverage that have noted in the four
daily newspapers
that i receive regarding what the the uh
uh regarding what the effects are among
the living as a result of the
covenanting pandemic and what i consider
to be
degree of hysteria and panic that has
developed an association with the viral
phenomenon
can you can you unpack that for the rest
of us yes
in today's new york times there's a
report about a 24
increase in mental health problems
among children between the ages of 5 and
that since this covered lockdown um
child abuse cases physically have risen
drug abuse deaths have risen suicides
have risen
and that's before in domestic situations
you can imagine
being locked up as a woman with a root
for a husband and a father with the
children for nine months
what that must be like think of all the
millions of lies that have been
destroyed
the thousands of people who line up in
their cars to get a box of food
millions of children going to bed hungry
every day and so on
think about it those numbers of
morbidity and mortality
far exceed the number of people who have
died
from covet and the number of people who
have died from covet that number is
vastly inflated
when you die in a hospital and you have
strokes and multiple
myocardial infarctions heart attacks
metastatic tumor and so on
but then you acquire covet in the final
days
they signed your death eye as covert uh
i do not believe
the lockdowns for people under the age
of 60 and certainly in
among children at elementary and high
school in college and postgraduate level
should have been done i think that
should not have occurred people who
needed protection
should have gotten the utmost degree of
protection in nursing homes
elderly disabled people who suffer from
chronic ailments and so on
these people have to be very careful
indeed and they have to be
the recipients of the best possible care
and preventive medical measures that can
be undertaken
but to have locked down as we have done
and the lives that have been destroyed
the fortunes that have been lost and you
know this is going to be played out
we're not we haven't seen the end of
this yet
uh i think this is far far in excess
i think that a great degree of panic and
hysteria set in
the situation also became markedly
politicized
um and and putting those together and
you have
the debacle of the great tragedies that
exist
today now i think it's important for the
audience to know you're you're a
and you may correct me on this you're
are you a registered independent or
registered democrat
i'm a registered democrat and you're a
registered democrat and you're saying
this so it's not like you're giving a
political message you're just giving an
exact right of my family i'm not a
i'm not a trump uh right that's that's
that's the point because
by the way have you had covet yet
yourself or no no i'm getting a vaccine
next week because i do coroner work oh
autopsies
um no i haven't are you not scared why
are you not scared you're having dinner
how come you're not concerned about it
no no it's not that you know i
brazen and vote um when i go into a
store where i have to wear a mask i do
but you know i don't wear a mask here in
my office i don't wear a mask when our
family 21 gets together
we don't sit there with masks and so on
and i said two of my
um kids are our doctors and so on
i don't know this everybody has to deal
with it the way
that they feel they're comfortable with
um and uh
you know the mask brigaders as i call
them
uh fine they they want to save lives
and somehow they are unmindful totally
unmindful of
all the lives that they are costing uh
because
of their um very zealot endeavors
do you agree with anthony fauci's
approach to covet and the lockdowns and
shutdowns and shutting down of the
schools et cetera et cetera would you
have a different perspective than which
fouchy's done
no i admire and respect dr farci whom i
met with
many years ago at a private dinner in
washington d.c
to a mutual friend and so on i think
he's a great man
however i disagree as i've already said
with these total
lockdowns and by the way you know i'm
not alone
there are a lot of scientific studies i
just read one from israel
signed off by a hundred top scientists
including
nobel laureates and so on and a lot of
people uh
who are questioning uh these things
about the mask and the
and the lockdowns and so on you know we
have to deal with these things we dealt
with
aids and ebola and and zika uh
and uh um and we're dealing with flu
and so on the death rate from flu and
pneumonia every year
exchange the death rate from covet you
deal with these things
and pastor we're going to have other
regrettable
epidemics like this are there going to
be you think this is the end
no more will there be viruses whether
they come from china
or elsewhere no of course it's going to
happen again so what are you going to
keep closing down
society then let's pack up the world and
go off to mars
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]
you